all right Tony
uh where are you from origin where'd you
grow up I grew up in the San Fernando
Valley
tell me about your family growing up uh
uh San Fernando Valley mother grew up in
Glendale
um father never met him so I don't know
a lot about him
oh you describe your childhood in
general
um
I I would say for the most part it was
good there was some dysfunction in the
family of course you know with drug
abuse and uh
you know um
missing male figures in the house
but for the most part I would say it was
it was it was okay
it was okay
what kind of stuff are you getting into
as a young man
um
I was pretty much a good kid
um growing up you know I listened you
know because Mom's you know she would
put it down she would you know she was
with the
whooping your ass if you had it coming
um
I would say
growing up was pretty rough
and I started messing up I would say
around the age of 15 that's when I tried
cocaine crack cocaine
I was 15. yeah almost yeah 14 I was I
just turned 15.
and uh
didn't really
latch onto it but was still dibbling and
dabbling in it
um
didn't do all that good in school but I
did go to school because I love sports
you know played Sports all through High
School
was at least as much as I could
um
I have two sisters and another brother
and Two Step Brothers
um
we used to do a lot of moving around
for sure
um
witnessed a lot of uh abuse you know
towards my mom with some of the male
figures that were you know coming into
our lives growing up
but for the most part I could honestly
say that you know she did a good job
yeah
you graduated high school no didn't
graduate high school but I went all the
way through to my senior year but didn't
graduate
and what'd you do after school
um after school was pretty much when uh
my disease took off
the cocaine crack cocaine
um it pretty much After High School
started smoking dough
running the streets
running with you know gang members and
stuff
um
in and out of prison
for most of my adult life
I guess you could say I was searching
for something you know
I I guess you could call them daddy
issues you know
but um yeah I mean
my drug addiction is what really my
addiction to crack cocaine was what
really just took me over the top you
know doing a lot of stupid [ __ ] you know
I think cracks a drug you can't really
be functional on right um no you can't
that's it's definitely not a drug you
know and then as far as financially you
know that that juggle it'll it'll put us
toll so you ended up on Skid Row
I ended up on Skid Row after I got out
of prison and uh I got out of prison in
2009
and uh let me rewind back I have a 26
year old son
and um I haven't spoke to him in
probably 15 years
my mother's Ray my mother raised him too
of course I was in and out of prison I
did quite a stretch
throughout the 90s and into 2000s
and uh when I got out in 2009
is when I met my youngest son his name
is Jaden he's 11.
and right away just jumped into the
family thing you know
didn't want to didn't want to use drugs
no more wanted to you know get get my
[ __ ] right
um she had three kids already which was
a big responsibility
went to work got a good job was going to
school at the same time ended up getting
a good job at a company in La I don't
want to put the company out there and uh
making real good money almost 100 000 a
year
and um five years into our relationship
my son was already four years old my
youngest and I found out you know my uh
significant other was having an affair
threw me over the top I just went crazy
came down here in 2015 just to get high
and never left
here it is what 2022. you're still here
and I'm still here but
but a year and three months ago I got
sober
I decided I need to get sober you know
that's what I really wanted
um
all those years I was down here I ended
up going back to prison in and out of
jail multiple times
for some pretty serious [ __ ] too
um you're down here in Skid Row smoking
crack smoking crack tell me about the
hustlins you know doing whatever I had
to do to get money but what goes on on
skid row at night right
it's it's it's a whole nother world the
scandalous this is the only place that I
know of and I've done some traveling
where you could literally be a bomb
and get high every day for free
literally
you know I mean everything's provided
for you down here it's the ones that
want it or the ones that are gonna you
know use that to their advantage you
know
but yeah it's um it was a rough ride man
living in a tent for [ __ ] four years
you know
on drugs tracking
you know what what made you turn the
corner or make a decision um you know
it's funny this is what turned the
corner for me because I'm I'm a one drug
man I never mess with no other drugs but
crack cocaine
and of course alcohol
and
I ended up buying some crack
one time with uh some fentanyl in it
this was
about a year and a half ago
and um it scared the [ __ ] out of me
you know because that feeling of just
like everything just felt so good slowly
going away I just like literally felt
myself going away
and I didn't I didn't like that feeling
yeah
and um when I woke up I thought somebody
had drugged me and robbed me you know
because that happens down here you know
people will give me [ __ ] to knock you
out and Rob you or do whatever else they
they want to do
um
and that that really opened my eyes you
know that made me realize that you know
what
I kind of liked it the other way killing
myself slowly smoking crack that way is
not cool I didn't like that
so I decide I just it happens to a lot
of crack addicts though because yeah you
know that's that's the part that that's
so scary is because they look the same
the fentanyl is not killing the fentanyl
users it's killing the other drug users
the crystal meth users the crack users
kill users yeah the ones that that that
don't know nothing about fentanyl the
ones that are on Fenton all know what
they're smoking they got used to it yeah
their bodies are right right so it was
uh it was pretty scary man you know the
fentanyl went pretty hard out here you
know I mean what four years ago they
were finding the stuff all over skid row
it's like people were just dropping bags
of it big bags everywhere
and it just kind of took off
um
and that shit's kind of scary man you
know and growing up in you know all my
family members all use drugs I mean my
brother's sober now
and uh one of my sisters is rest in
peace and then my other sister she's you
know
she's doing real bad so it made me
realize that you know that's that's not
what I want man
you know I like sober Tony
a lot
so I decided to get clean man and you
know but I mean people would literally
have bets on me out here like man nobody
does what you did he's not gonna he's
just talking like everybody else man I
want to get off dope I want to get off
dope
and uh I just didn't say nothing to
nobody you know and I'm gonna tell you
that that um I think the worst part
about all of it was the detox and the
alcohol because I was drinking probably
close to a fifth of vodka a day and
that's not counting the the flavor
drinks in between
you know so the alcohol
um was uh yeah I felt like I was gonna
die
I mean I was literally I was so bad that
I couldn't even get off of my bed to go
use the restroom I would just literally
roll off to the side of my bed and piss
inside my tent right on the floor it was
that bad that's how weak I was
so getting off alcohol is harder than
correct oh my God yes by far
by far
and um I just knew I didn't want to go
through that no more
you know I've seen it a million times
you know I used to say to people on that
come on man suck it up it ain't that bad
but it's it's that bad but your mental
part is where you gotta really be
careful with because there's still times
where I think about getting high
you know you've been playing for a year
and a half a year and three months oh
you're in three months right and you
still think about it I still think about
it I still think about it sometimes what
helps you
um I'll call somebody or I'll just get
up and do something or smoke a cigarette
try to take my mind off of it jump on my
phone you know look at some pictures or
something and you're working now yeah
been working been working um
the real test was went off
the love of my life took her own life
that's that really pushed me to the edge
that just happened recently yeah it just
happened recently about almost three
months ago
and that was real hard that I took that
real hard from China yeah I've man I
mean
you know she was my everything and all I
wanted was for her to you know get get
herself together too she was doing good
she was using she was using fentanyl she
was using fentanyl regularly yeah yeah
and um and it was hard for me to even
accept that but you know I thought it
was gonna you know be a a process of her
because you know when we first got
together she was a hot mess man
you know and I was barely two months
sober
so
it um
it definitely it was weird because I
used to lean on her for strength and she
never even knew it
you know
staying sober for both of us even though
she was still you know getting loaded
oh yeah I used to it used to break me
down I was pretty stressed out for the
last couple months that we were together
but uh that was just like um that was
definitely like the nail
in that last little chapter of how bad I
want to stay away from drugs or how bad
they are and
a combination of mental illness doesn't
help you know because she was she was
battling with depression you know we all
go through it I still have my little
issues you know I have anxiety issues
since I stopped drinking and stop using
my little health problems are popping up
now you know anxiety
um
uh get nervous when I have to do just go
pay a bill or go stand in lines all of a
sudden I'm you know getting anxiety you
know so stuff like that I got to deal
with
um when I first got sober I thought all
my problems were going to go away but
they don't
you know you just learned to manage them
and deal with them a little differently
um but yeah sobrieties I love it how did
you how did you get off crack did you
just I just cut back each day or
um yeah actually what I started doing
like about a month or two before I um
before I quit I actually uh
started only I would only smoke crack at
night
the daytime is when I would hustle you
know go work get to get all the things
that I needed you know to make it
through the night or even for tomorrow
and then once nighttime came that's when
I would smoke
but once that sun would come up that's
when I would shut it down because you
know that's what I didn't like people to
see me when I was high
you know I didn't like some of these
people don't mind excuse me running
these streets looking all crazy that I
care you know I don't like people to
know I do drugs you know
so it was it it definitely helped me
because there was times where you know I
didn't even want to smoke at night I'd
be like you know what that I feel good
right now it sounds to me like you have
a little bit of your self-worth intact
right where you you believe you deserve
better yes definitely and I know I know
I I have I have a purpose I have there's
something
or some things that I still need to
accomplish
you know and uh what they are I don't
completely know yet but I know right now
for today I want to be clean
and I just want to be as humble as
possible and get and get through
you know this process of whatever I'm
trying to repair
you know which is as far as mental
Financial you know
stuff like that it's it's important to
me it definitely is
any program or rehab no program
I mean last time I've been to a meeting
was when I when I had to you know I did
a 90-day program before my one of my POS
said you need to go to a programmer you
know just stay up in there for an extra
70 days so I chose a program and uh you
know I learned a lot in that program but
but to me it's it's all it's all on you
and the people you surround yourself
with that's very important
and not just that I feel like you know
there's there's a lot of a lot of good
that I can do down here to show people
that you can be done
it can be done yeah because you didn't
talk about what you were going to do
yeah I did it because I didn't you know
I didn't want people to happen I heard
that a million times though I've known
you for a while when I heard that you
were you were right clean and you've
been clean for a year I'm like whoa
really right you weren't bragging about
it you weren't yeah I was keeping it to
myself you know sometimes I'll tell
people you know they'll always say man
what's up you look good man that's with
sobriety or Duty man
you know you feel better oh definitely
you look better definitely
yeah definitely
I mean you remember when we first met
marks
I mean I know I was a hot mess man
you know
but now it's just um I'm just
I want to I want to get right because
not only that
my family's kind of shotguns you know
all my my nieces and nephews I have a
lot of nieces and nephews and um it's
gonna be important you know because
family is important especially as you
get older you tend to see that a little
bit more like damn you know I could
still do what I like to do but family's
important you need them sometimes or you
they need you so
so right now I'm just focused on me and
my son and my family and just you know
trying to trying to get through this is
as best way as I can howdy I'll be 53 in
July 53. yeah
how many good years left plenty of good
years left I said I wanted to live to be
a hundred let's see what happens
we'll see what happens a better chance
now at a better chance you know
Antonio what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
um
how precious life is
for sure
I've seen a lot of people die down here
a lot of people died on there you know
and some of them I was real close to
you know on the street left
you know
um but yeah
life
it's it's precious because it's fast
it's short
it really is
you know life is is like that
hmm
all right Tony proud of you thank you
Mark thank you man
it's awesome